ça me racontez nous comment se portent
les britanniques à quelques heures de se
braque sites historiques
écoutez sophie la ville et un chip est
en effervescence et surtout ici dans le
quartier de westminster où les gens
commencent à fumer il ya beaucoup plus
de journalistes que de personnes pour
l'instant d'après du monde entier
s'étaient donné rendez vous pour cette
journée historique pour les britanniques
celle qui va sceller le sort des
britanniques et leur permettre d'écrire
une nouvelle page de leur histoire
le royaume uni qui quittent enfin
l'union européenne après des mois et des
années de discussions et de débats
houleux d'une journée consacrée à ce
break site les festivités devraient
commencer à partir de 21h30 heure locale
ou ici même des prises de paroles des
débats un concert et même un écran géant
qui devrait être installé dans quelques
minutes qui pourraient permettra de
projeter un petit peu tous ces
événements et ses festivités qui auront
lieu durant le courant de la journée big
ben ne sonnera pas car big ben est en
travaux mais un jeu de sons et lumières
va représenter un petit peu le son de
cloche de big ben et puis le rendez vous
sera donné à partir de 23 heures du côté
de downing street ou le johnson le
premier ministre s'adressera à la nation
dans le cadre d'un discours historique
qui scellera sevrés exit et puis un
cadran sera reflétée sur la façade du
bâtiment qui sonnera les douze coups de
minuit d'où ce coup qui marqueront le
passage à une nouvelle ère pour les
britanniques
un divorce qui est scellée entre londres
et bruxelles
mais qui prendra à plus de 11 mois pour
définir les contours des nouveaux
accords et des nouveaux de nouvelles
relations entre londres et bruxelles
et puis bien sûr on reviendra dans le
cadre de prochaines éditions sur cette
journée historique que s'apprête à dire
les anglais d enlever qui sont quand
même divisée hier on a pu voir des
antilles brésil qui était ici même avec
des drapeaux une l'union européenne avec
des slogans anti à johnson se sont
donnés rendez vous encore une fois
aujourd'hui on a pu les apercevoir tout
à l'heure et puis on a même eu
l'occasion d'échanger quelques mots avec
certains parlementaires qui sont venus
se mêler un petit peu à la foule des
parlementaires pour la plupart prober
existent qui sont venus échanger
quelques mots avec la presse
internationale
et bien sûr on reviendra sur tous ces
éléments dans les prochaines éditions
merci beaucoup bassam chez vie en direct
de londres et à tout à l'heure